comme promis michel morvant michèle
bourgon qui prend des risques la plus
connue la plus couronnée d actrice du
cinéma français n'avait jamais fait de
théâtre tout au long de sa carrière des
centaines de pièces lui avait été
proposé mais le moment de se remettre en
question n'étaient pas vu alors en
acceptant de jouer le tout pour le tout
de françoise dorin michel morvan a pris
en quelque sorte un pari avec elle même
sous la direction de raymond jérôme les
répétitions était tenue secrète mais à
travers ce reportage de georges bégoux
vous serez seul a assisté aux premiers
pas de michel maure gants sur la scène
du palais royal
chaque fois qu'on proposait une pièce je
trouvais une bonne excuse je disais non
là le rôle n'est pas comme ci ou la
pièce n'est pas exactement ce que je
devrais faire ou à refaire je trouvais
toujours une bonne raison pour
finalement refusé ce qu'on me ferait
cette fois ci ça a été très difficile
parce que la pièce est excellente du
moins je le pense vraiment le rôle par m
me convenir à merveille parce que
finalement c'est un des personnages au
point de vue du caractère qui est le
plus proche je crois de ce que je suis
dans la vie c'est à dire un personnage
contrairement à au rôle que j'ai joué au
cinéma c'est un personnage assez gai
assez tonique assez optimiste et je
crois à l'être dans la vie coûte et
monsieur me payer je suis pas venu ici
pour écouter vos brèche signer pour
jouer alors déjà lui cédera vous pouvez
partir votre jeu ne nous intéresse pas
du tout attendez on n'a pas encore
commencé si vous avez commencé le bolide
les serpents ça s'était amusé à a
parce que vous aviez pas dit autre chose
pour nous oui ça quasiment du waf la
thénardier
combien pourquoi faire l'amour avec
chaque wii mais vous êtes complètement
la mission quoi fin 8 10 6 millions
chacun pour quasimodo la thénardier
c'est quand même bien payé ça vaut la
peine de réfléchir lors mm pour 1
milliard jeune réfugié à présent et pour
monsieur dit oui à je crois que j'ai eu
2 2 moment de courage dans ma vie
professionnellement c'est lorsque
j'avais 15 ans je suis parti de chez moi
pour un peu inconsciente d'ailleurs deux
moments de courage et peut-être
d'inconscience mais je ne crois pas que
cette fois ci ce soit de l'inconscience
plus maintenant c'est lorsque je suis
parti pour aller suivre les cours de
rené simon et g
j'ai décidé à 15 ans que je serai
comédienne et pour ça il fallait
beaucoup de courage car j'habitais la
province est bon enfin il a fallu des
circonstances et que je force les
circonstances et puis je crois cette
fois ci après ont combien d'années de
métier de cinéma que tout à coup je
prenne le risque qu'on critique ou qu'on
ne trouve pas donc on n'est même pas sur
une scène de terre je ne sais pas c'est
un risque et je n'étais pas obligé de le
prendre et je les prie par jeu par
amusement pour pourvoir comme ça